let's say we have a hundred light bulbs
instead of let me actually just draw
them so i have one light bulb
there
i have another light bulb
and i have a hundred of them
a hundred light bulbs and what i'm gonna
do is first i'm gonna go well actually
before i even start turning in these
light bulbs on and off let me let you
know that they are all off so they start
off
they start
now the next thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to number the 100 light bulb
i'm going to number them one through 100
so the first light bulb is light bulb 1
the second light bulb is light bulb 2
all the way to light bulb 100
and what i'm going to do is first i'm
going to go and i'm going to switch i'm
going to switch every light bulb
that
essentially every light bulb i'm going
to go and i'm going to so if i go i'm
going to switch if they all start off
i'm going to turn them all on right so
they'll all be you know let me do it so
on my first pass so let's call this pass
one
pass
so on pass one i'm going to turn all of
these on on
on
on they're all going to be turned on
and then in past two what i'm going to
do is i'm going to switch
only the light only every other light
bulb so for example i'll say okay i
won't i won't switch light bulb one i'll
only switch light bulb two so light bulb
one will stay on light bulb two will be
off
light bulb three will be on light bulb
four will be off
and so essentially every light bulb if
you look at their numbers that is a
multiple of two will be switched so 100
will be switched so that will also be
off
then i'm going to come
and ignore this right here and i'm going
to switch every third light bulb so
what's going to happen
this one's going to let me switch colors
arbitrarily this one's going to stay on
this one's going to stay off and i'm
going to switch the third light bulb so
this one was on now this one will be off
the fourth light bulb will stay off
because i'm not touching it the fifth
light bulb will
what was it before the fifth the light
bulb would have been on and will stay on
and now the sixth light bulb in this
case we switch it off and now it'll be
on again but i think you get the point
every third light bulb or if we look at
the numbers of the light bulb every
every numbered light bulb that is a
multiple of three is going to be
switched and if it was a multiple of
three and two it would have been
switched
on the first time and then off the
second time but i get i think you're
getting the point but what i'm going to
do is i'm going to do a hundred passes
so the first pass i switch every light
bulb they all started off so they're all
going to be turned on the second pass i
switch every other light bulb or every
second light bulb the third pass i do
every light bulb every third one or
that's a multiple of three
and my question to you is
after a hundred passes
so after 100 passes
after
100 passes
100 passes how many light bulbs are
still on
or how many are on period how
many
are
on
and that is the brain teaser how do you
figure out of out of the hundred which
ones are going to be on and you should
be able to do this in your head you
don't have to make like an excel
spreadsheet and actually do all the on
and off switches how do we know so the
first question is how many of these are
going to be on after i do 100 passes and
just to make it clear what's the 100th
pass going to be well i'm only going to
switch every 100th light bulb so i'm
only whatever this light bulb is already
doing i'm just going to switch it if it
was off it'll be come on if it was on
it'll become off so the first question
is how many of these are going to be on
after 100 passes and then the bonus
question is which of these are going to
be on
and so that's the question pause it
if if you don't want the answer and then
try to solve it i think it shouldn't
take you too much time but now i'm going
to give you the answer
or maybe i'll start with a couple of
hints so we know
when do we know that a light bulb is is
being switched
so if i'm on the second pass i will turn
on i'll i don't want to say turn on it
might already be on i will switch every
light bulb that's divisible by two
and then if i'm on the third pass i'll
switch every light bulb this divisible
by three so on every pass what am i
doing
when when on if i if i'm if i'm on pass
n
this is a hint
if you want it
if i'm on pass n
pass n what do i know i know all the
light bulbs that are numbered that where
n is a factor of that light bulb that
will get switched right so we know that
switched
if
n
is a
factor
of the
light bulb number
light bulb
number and that's just a fancy way of
saying look if i'm on pass 17 i'm going
to switch all the multiples of 17 or i
could say i know that i'm going to
switch light bulb 51 because 17 is a
factor of 51.
so that tells you that we're always
going to be switching one of these light
bulbs on or off when
one of its factors is our pass right so
for example
for example if we're looking at
if we're looking at light bulb
let me draw a light bulb
light bulb eight this is light bulb
eight so when will it be switched so on
pass one we're definitely going to
switch it on so pass one is going to be
switched on
past two it'll be switched off i know
that because two is divisible into eight
pass three is nothing's going to happen
past four and past three nothing's gonna
happen because this isn't a multiple of
three
past four
what'll happen it will be switched it'll
be that switched back on
and then what's the and then pass eight
is the next time we'll touch this light
bulb and it'll be switched back
off
so every time one of its factors go by
we're going to switch this thing and as
you can see
in order for it to be on at the end you
have to have an odd number of factors so
that's an interesting thing
so in order for a light bulb to be on
so
for light bulb
to
be
on
has to
have
odd number
of factors
now that's an interesting question or
what numbers have an odd number of
factors and this is something that i
think they should teach you in grade
school and they never do but it's a
really interesting
kind of number theory it's a simple one
but it's interesting to think about so
what what numbers are true let's let's
do all the factors for some of the
starting numbers so all the factors of
one well one the only factor is just one
so one works one has an odd number of
factors so that means that one will
remain on because you're only going to
turn it on in the first pass make sense
two what are all the factors of two well
you have one and two
so two it has an even number you're
gonna switch it on the first time and
then off the second time then you're
never gonna touch it again so this is
gonna stay off
three your factors are one and three
four your factors are one
two
and four
interesting here we have three factors
right we have an odd number of factors
so four is going to stay
on we're going to turn it on when our
first pass we're going to turn it off on
our second pass and we're going to turn
it on again in our fourth pass let's
keep going
so five
the factors of five are one and five
six the factors are one two three and
six it's an even number so it's going to
be off when we're all done with it
seven it's one and seven
eight we just did that it's one two four
and eight still going to be off
nine
let's see nine the factors are one
three and nine
interesting once again we have an odd
number of factors so nine is also going
to be the light bulb number nine is also
going to be on
when everything's done let's keep going
i don't know you know maybe actually we
did this at our mental boot camp and
some of the kids immediately they said
oh you know the distance between one and
four is three and the difference between
four and nine is the distance between
four and nine is five and maybe the
distance between nine and the next
number is going to be 7 right it
increases by odd numbers and that's
what's 9 plus 7. let's just try that out
16.
what are the factors of 16
they're 1
and 16.
interesting that worked right from 9 to
16 you incremented by seven from from
four to nine equals by five so it seems
like we have a pattern but can you see
something even more interesting about
the numbers one
9 and 16. you could try all the numbers
between 9 and 16 and you'll see that
they have an even number of factors but
what's what's interesting about all of
these numbers what why do they have an
odd number of factors in all of these
other cases every factor is paired with
another number right 1 times 2 is 2. 1
times 6 is 6 2 times 3 is 6. there's
always a pair except for these numbers
there's no pair right why isn't there 1
times 4 is 4
but two times two
is also four so we only write the two
once three times three is nine four
times four is sixteen so all of the
lights that are going to be on are
actually perfect squares that's why they
have an odd number of factors
so
all right what's our question how many
so the question this problem of what
light bulbs are going to be on boils
down to how many perfect squares are
there between 1 and 100 and if you you
know you could just list them out and
you could say oh well that's just you
know the perfect squares are 1 4
9 16 and you could try to think them all
or you could say as well how many
numbers can i square and get a number
less than 100 or less than equal to 100
well 100 is equal to
100 is equal to 10 squared so you can
only square the numbers between 1 and 10
to get a perfect square so there's only
10 perfect squares between 1 and 100
right hopefully you didn't lose that but
if that confuses you just list them all
out you have to you know given that 100
is the largest number
it's the largest perfect square there
and that's 10 squared
the only other perfect squares in the in
our range we're talking about are 1
squared 2 squared 3 squared all the way
up to 10 squared and we could do that 4
squared is 16
5 squared is 25
36 49 64.
81 and 100. so these the numbers with
these the light bulbs with these numbers
on it are the ones that will stay lit
when we're all done anyway hope you
enjoyed that